do you know how hard it is to be that
mean to harry melling
he is like the sweetest individual in
the world
because uh yes he played harry his name
is harry melling
and you i mean that was exciting for you
to do a scene with harry melling it's a
moment
yeah yeah it was her rihanna
tell us why tell us why he meant so much
to you well i
learned to speak english reading the
harry potter books so as lame as it
sounds those characters really were my
first friends
um so still a big fan of the harry
potter franchise love the movies
oh my god look at him he played dudley
dursley i mean he's not an obvious one
but so many people don't come up to him
all the time
he's still part of the universe
and so what what language were you
speaking when you learned
to speak english through harry potter
spanish
oh okay and yeah so when did you come to
london
when i was six but i only learned
english when i was eight because i was
convinced that if i didn't speak the
language my parents would have to take
me home
and that failed miserably so had to
[Music]
learn